i have difficulty ascribing reason to  current behaviors because i think we  just don't know why i could create 16  different stories around why i am this  way and i could probably find people who  have similar character traits to me who  were not only children so was it the  fact that i was an only child that made  me this way who knows i never got  chocolate as a kid and that's why you  chocolate now i'm like well maybe you  just like chocolate maybe has nothing to  do with the fact you didn't have this  kid and so people use circumstances to  explain current reality as though it's a  reason for rather than just like  accepting it for what it is which is i  just am this way